good afternoon my name is adrian dix
mbc's minister of health to my right is
dr bonnie henry bc's provincial health
officer this is our kova 19 briefing for
tuesday february the 1st
we're honored to be here on the
territory of the musqueam of the
squamish of the slave tooth first
nations and we're honored to be here
today on their lands
and uh as you'll be aware dr henry will
be giving a a presentation today and so
the slides will be available
through the bccdc's website and through
government websites
after the presentation and with that
it's my honor to introduce dr bonnie
henry
thank you very much and good afternoon
thank you for joining us today on the
first day of the
prison for
our future as well
i want to start off today by talking a
little bit about our
treatment update so as you know uh two
weeks ago health canada approved
another tool that we have in our toolbox
to help us manage this pandemic and that
is a medication called paxlovid which is
a combination of two drugs
nurmatrovir and rotonover retonavir
and it was given uh what one of the
things that we needed to do was uh get a
better understanding of who would best
be suited for this drug here in british
columbia and how we could use it with
the limited amounts that we received to
begin with so our bc covet 19
therapeutics committee and very grateful
for all the work they've been doing over
these past two years
they set about
trying to come up with
our rational approach to how we're going
to use this
this is another positive step forward in
our covet 19 journey and the treatment
is specifically for people who are at
highest risk of having more severe
illness and hospitalization and it needs
to be started within five days of
symptom onset so for that of course we
need to make sure that we have testing
available for people so we've been
aligning both
the
limited supply we have about 4 000
treatment courses of this these
medications um with our testing strategy
as well
and i'm very grateful for the infectious
disease teams in each of our health
authorities we have developed a hub and
spoke model so that this medication can
be available through our infectious
disease teams and they are able to
identify people who are
for this very initial supply of
medication uh who are most at risk and
who we can get it to in that critical
period of time and you will recall to
fridays ago we presented a heat map and
we use that information to identify
those people in british columbia who are
more at risk of of requiring hospital
care
and we've identified that it is
essentially the people who are in our
critically extremely vulnerable groups
one and two so those are those people
who have immune compromising conditions
because of medications that they're on
because of having had a transplant or
undergoing certain cancer therapies
so
those are the people who will now be uh
have access to this drug the things that
we are learning though from this
medication
is that it is these are conditional
recommendations and the this is a very
challenging medication combination
every medication comes with risks and
benefits but this new
antiviral combination has some very
important what we call contraindication
so can't be used in some cases and it
also has some
very important drug drug interactions
so unfortunately many of the people who
would potentially benefit from this
medication take some of those
medications that interact with it
and it makes it very different from some
of the other antivirals we have like
tamiflu for example
so people with the in
we have to be mindful of people's kidney
function
the immune suppressant medications are
on anticoagulants these are some of the
very serious interactions
so our teams who are most familiar with
using these antiviral drugs particularly
rotonovir which is a protease inhibitor
it's part of a combination of drugs that
we also use for uh treating people with
hiv they will be starting to offer uh
pax lavid and
two people at the highest risk groups
and we'll be reaching out to them
through a proactive process of
monitoring our lab data so it is
important if you are one of those high
risk people to continue
to access lab testing as you
are part of the testing guidelines and
along with this we will be posting later
today
some of the detailed information for
people so they can look at whether they
qualify for this medication but also the
updated testing guidelines to make sure
that people who do qualify for it are
able to get a test
quickly and rapidly and i just want to
say
my thanks again to our our infectious
disease teams in the health authorities
but also to the the teams at the bc
renal bc cancer and bc transplant
because we know that you'll be reaching
out and having these discussions with
your high risk patients
this of course is is another tool but as
i said there's still much that we need
to learn about about how to use it and
who it can be used in and what the side
effects and the risks and benefits are
and most importantly it is used once
somebody has been infected and is at
risk of having
severe enough illness to need
hospitalization
and we know that the most important
thing we can do is prevent infection in
the first place and particularly in
people who are at high risk the
importance of vaccination and
that
is one of the things that reminds us
that we need to pay attention to in
increasing immunity particularly if you
are somebody vulnerable
and so in that light in mid-january we
shared that we are updating how we'll
report on hospitalizations to provide a
more fulsome account of everybody who is
in hospital with covet 19 positive test
on any given day
and we are at the highest levels of
people that we've had in hospital in
this whole pandemic
hospitalizations are what we call a
lagging indicator it takes time and we
have had very high levels of
transmission in the community for some
time now
and we have seen this translate into
into hospitalizations most recently and
this is where we are
experiencing at the moment
so i'm going to walk us through the
information that we've done to look at
who is in hospital right now when we
presented the updating reporting we
talked about the census data so it
includes everybody who's in hospital
because of covet 19 whether the covet 19
is causing respiratory illness
or exacerbation of other underlying
conditions like heart disease or lung
disease
so
people who are admitted because of covet
19 and we're also looking at people who
are admitted to hospital with covet 19.
so they're admitted for another reason
and they either
acquired in hospital or
somebody is screened or tested
with either very mild illness or because
they've been screened on admission
and those are the people who are
admitted not because of covet 19 but
with a positive lab test and we need to
understand those two populations to help
us understand how we're going to get
through this phase
so what we have here is a familiar slide
of
the pandemic to date
what we've seen in terms of of
hospitalizations and particularly what
we're looking at in the in the last
last month so we've had 63 new people
sorry
we've had 706 new people admitted to
hospital this week as of the 30th of
january the week ending the 30th of
january out of 11 539 new cases as we
can see from the blue line it does look
like we are at our peak of
hospitalizations and this is where we
would expect to be
given the modeling that we've been using
to help help us understand the
trajectory
the other thing that we look at of
course is by age who is getting admitted
in higher rates than others and what we
are seeing that it's coming down along
all age groups
that bump up that we saw in the younger
zero to 19 year age group has leveled
off and is also starting to come down
so when we look at who is in hospital
there's a number of important things to
look at one of them is what is the
variant of concern that's causing
hospitalization right now so as we can
see it takes a bit of time for us to do
the whole genome sequencing once
somebody's been admitted to hospital to
understand exactly what strain they have
but it's very clear that
as we've progressed into january omicron
has been
more and more of the
cause
related to hospitalization the strain
related to hospitalization overtaking
delta although we still have people in
hospital
with delta people being admitted because
of infections with delta as well
if we look at the characterizations of
people who are hospitalized
using this breakdown between delta and
omicron we can compare and see what the
differences are in what we're seeing
and one of the important things we're
seeing is that
delta for the most part was very
strongly hospitalization from delta was
much more common in people who were not
vaccinated
now with omicron the unvaccinated are
smaller proportion
and partly that's because uh some of the
people a good proportion of people in
hospital now have that data to show you
are people who are admitted for other
reasons and have a positive cova test so
it's not covet that's driving them into
hospital
the median age is about the same and i
think this is something important early
on when we're trying to understand if
omicron causes more severe illness than
delta or not
we we're seeing it more in younger
people so it was hard to tell if it was
because people were younger and
vaccinated or
because it was milder in and of itself
we are now seeing that we're in that
older age group that is requiring
hospitalization so that gives us some
hint
we're also seeing that the proportion of
people over age 80 is now higher which
gives us a sense as well about two
things one is
people over age 80 are still at highest
risk of having severe illness this is
something we've seen all along whether
they're vaccinated or not we also know
that people over age 80 are much more
likely to have other underlying
illnesses which may be a reason why they
are admitted to hospital and could be
screened for covet
the length of stay that we're seeing
which is really important in how we
manage our hospital
care right now and the burden of people
who are in hospital right now
particularly when we know that
healthcare workers are off with uh with
illness themselves so what we are seeing
thankfully is that we continue to see a
shorter length of stay approximately
half the time
that people are in hospital with the
omicron compared to delta and so that
does mean that people who have been
admitted in december and january are
still in hospital and many more of those
people
would be from delta
that were in for a longer period of time
we also thankfully see a much smaller
proportion of people requiring critical
care so that is either a supplemental
oxygen in the icu or ventilation and
other
important interventions to keep the the
circulation and blood system going and
we are also thankfully seeing a much
lower rate of death in people who are
hospitalized about half the rate
in now
so what does this mean overall
so if we look at our hospital admissions
and this is done from detailed chart
reviews of 550 people across the
province so i had presented two weeks
ago some very similar data that came out
of vancouver coastal we've now done the
chart review of the 550 people who were
admitted to hospital
so they're on admission some of those
people are still in hospital today some
of them would have been discharged by
now
and this is
across the province
and broken it down by people who were
admitted to hospital because of covet
19. so the the reason for admission was
because they had respiratory symptoms
and or exacerbation of their underlying
conditions because of covet
and we see there's 218 about 40 percent
of this
chart review were people who were
admitted because of covid and about 16
percent additionally required critical
care
and
over the period of time that we looked
at in december and january
there were non-covet 19 related
admissions where the reason for
admission was not related to covet 19
but they had a positive cova test and
that was about 244 or 44 percent of the
cases
but when we look at this um by breaking
it and breaking it down
by the variant of concerns
that we that we know are causing um
infections in hospital we can see that
for people
with delta it is primarily people being
admitted because of covet 19 and a much
higher proportion of those people are
requiring critical care
and so that's important for us to know
this issue of people who are admitted to
hospital with other diagnoses and test
positive really is related to what we
are seeing in the last few weeks as
omicron has spread so much in the
community and we can see that about 60
percent of admissions that were related
to
omicron
were not because of the infection but
people who were admitted and tested and
found to have a positive test so this is
important and for those that we don't
yet have
the whole genome sequencing that we see
that the patent though those are more
recent cases for the most part the
pattern is very similar to what we're
seeing with omicron so that's telling us
as omicron has spread in the communities
we are more likely to to pick it up when
people are admitted to hospital for
other reasons and those other reasons
are what keep them in hospital or
requiring
our reasons why
they're in for a period of time
there is of course still an important
about 40 percent of the people who are
admissions because of covet because of
their underlying illness and a much
smaller proportion compared to people
who are admitted with a delta infection
are people who require critical care
so obviously we want to see how that
breaks down by vaccination status as
well and we can see again a different
pattern for delta than for what we see
with the omicron so particularly if we
were calling it and it was so apparent
when you look at this that having at
least one dose of vaccine so this
includes people who have one doses two
doses or three doses so any vaccine is
very highly protective when you had
delta circulating in the community and
for people who are unvaccinated you are
much more likely to end up
with hospital needing hospital care and
we'll look at age in a minute and a much
higher proportion
required critical care so this is
important as we've moved to omicron we
see that the incidental cases are much
more common in people who are not
vaccinated sorry people who have at
least one dose of vaccine and you're
much less likely to be admitted because
of covid related illness or to require
critical care
and the pattern that we're seeing in
those who we don't yet have the
variant of concern is much more similar
to omicron
again it just shows us the importance
and how we're getting through this phase
of this pandemic with so much
transmission of omicron how important it
is that vaccination is preventing people
from needing hospital care because of
their covet infection
the other part that we want to look at
is you know is this different by age and
the answer for that is again yes so if
you are
admitted uh for
a covid you you are much likely to be
younger in delta so delta is causing
more severe infections in younger people
and as we've just seen in younger people
who are more likely to be unvaccinated
whereas with omicron in younger people
it's much more likely to be an admission
for something else where you had a
positive screening test for om for covet
19.
and finally just trying to put this all
together and determine if
if this is um if omicron itself is less
virulent than delta we do see that that
seems to be the case with the data that
we have
that shows that
if we match everybody and regardless of
age of vaccination status of the other
comorbidities you may have or other
illnesses and sex and health authority
that there's about half as much chance
of being
of
being hospitalized with omicron the odds
of being hospitalized with omicron are
much less than with uh with delta but
importantly i mean 1.3 percent risk of
hospitalization is still very high when
you have thousands of people a day who
are being infected and we see from this
these data that it's incredibly
important that we the high levels of
vaccination that we have in our
communities across the board across age
groups and across communities has made
the difference in ensuring that our
hospitals were not overwhelmed in this
past few weeks
so what does this tell us
ninety percent of these new hospital
admissions are omicron as i mentioned
people with delta stay in hospital
longer are more likely to have severe
illness
and the vast majority of those requiring
care in hospital were a result of
in delta were a result of actually from
covet today we have far more people in
hospital than we've ever had
and many of those people as much as 60
or 70 percent now especially younger
people are there for other reasons and
they've tested positive and so what this
tells us is this is
really important the level of immunity
that we have in our community has
protected our health care system at this
most critical time
even when we've had the numbers of
people who needed that hospital care
so while it is under severe strain it is
the credit of so many who have stepped
up and got that protection that our
hospitals are coping
even though we're stretched
the other
measures that have made a difference and
we know that i was intervening early
with some of those measures in our
community that reduces the risk of
transmission reduces the number of
people that we've gone been in contact
with
so that is has been an important measure
as well and we're looking forward to
when we can start to
lift some of those measures but right
now it still remains important to do
those things that work
knowing that one point three percent of
of 2000 people a day or 1500 people a
day is still a large number of people
who could need hospital care
so
with the increase in transmission in our
communities we've also seen an increase
in in people who have coveted in our
long-term care and seniors assisted
living facilities and we've seen that
reflected in the numbers of outbreaks
that we're seeing
and while there is no question that
again our seniors and elders in care are
being affected we are seeing a
difference very similar to what we saw
in hospital where the severity of
illness for most is far less and this is
absolutely because of the very high
levels of vaccination and booster doses
in residents of long-term care and in
staff
in previous surges we needed to take
blanket measures one size fits all
across the province
when we had high levels of community
transmission to prevent
and this virus from entering into our
long-term care homes
those protocols had impacts themselves
and we know that
now while some measures continue to
apply
we are adjusting this outbreak
management approach reflecting very high
levels of transmission but much less
severity for most people because of that
high level of protection we have through
through vaccination and through
short-term protection through people
who've been infected now so this
one-size-fits-all approach is no longer
applicable and we've updated the
guidelines around management of
long-term care and visitors in long-term
care and those will be posted on the
bccdc website
later today
i will remind people we do have some
measures in place that were put in place
in december as omicron was starting to
increase and because of all of the
transmission that we're seeing in
communities so this includes things like
reducing the numbers of visitors it's
important that with the vaccination
status of staff and visitors and
residents making sure we got booster
doses into everybody
and wearing ppe at all times for
healthcare workers and when visitors are
in making sure that they're wearing ppe
that they only visit the person that
they're there to see but we are also
acutely aware of the impact of the
extended social isolation that comes
with the full closures of long-term care
homes and we've been trying to find that
balance of of minimizing the risk to
residents in long-term care minimizing
the transmission of the virus as well as
finding that balance of having that
all-important contact with our loved
ones and making sure that we can have
those social interactions that are so
important
it is important that we continue to have
that balance and um doors will be kept
open right now
that is the way that we've been trying
to manage this to allow all residents to
have up to two visitors
one at all times
regardless of whether there's an
outbreak whether there's some covet in
that facility and the community
transmission rates
so this is one essential visitor about a
third of residents of long-term care
have an essential designated visitor
already but for every resident of
long-term care they can have a
designated visitor so that can be too
for some people but a designated visitor
for every resident of their choice and
yes you can have a backup in case you
can't go but one at a time making sure
that we do have that all-important
connection with at least one additional
person and for many people two
additional people
even if there are cases of covet in the
facility
what remains unchanged is that these
visitors must be fully vaccinated
themselves that's how we re we manage
this risk and must continue to wear ppe
when it comes to declaring an outbreak
we're using a criteria approach based on
judgment and the scope and severity of
the outbreak and there are a number of
different factors that medical health
officers with our teams of infection
control and support for each facility
and working with the facility use when a
an outbreak
when there's transmission within the
facility and whether an outbreak needs
to be declared and what measures are in
place to try and manage that we also
have updated our guidance around timely
communication of outbreaks and cases in
long-term care and assisted living homes
so those details will be posted today
so that our focus continues to be to
protect those who are most vulnerable to
severe illness whether it's in the
community in long-term care in hospital
and that's why we all need to continue
to do the measures that we're doing to
protect our health care system to make
sure we can get through this wave too
and to keep our communities open and
going as much as possible it's about
finding once again and keeping our
balance
we know that covid19 this virus is going
to be with us for some time still
but we are progressing through this
surge which means we can look very soon
at starting to gradually ease
restrictions in the weeks ahead as we
get closer and we've put limits on on
some of the the restrictions on events
and gatherings that will be coming up
for review uh in the middle of february
and we'll look at what we're what where
we are in our uh journey through this
phase by that time
as we've done previously
it will not be a flick of the switch
it'll be again increasing
the dimmer switch a gradual turning of
the dial so that we can do this
cautiously and not
put people at risk as we're getting
closer and closer to the end of this
wave
it is a new lunar year a new month
and a time for cautious optimism but we
still have ways to go on our journey yet
and we all need to continue to do our
part as we progress through this
pandemic together thank you
is
uh thank you very much dr henry and
um
i wanted to start by
talking about the continuing and
extraordinary efforts of our vaccination
campaign across bc 10 million 778
839 doses administered as of last night
that's four point four million four
hundred and sixty thousand one hundred
and thirty first doses four million one
hundred sixty six thousand two hundred
five second doses
two million one hundred fifty two
thousand five hundred and four
third doses which is
uh in this recent period an
extraordinary effort i might add uh in
addition to that
that we see a very significant number of
young people now over fifty percent of
children five to eleven i should say
who have received uh their first dose of
a coven 19 vaccine and that
that number as of last night
is a hundred and eighty six thousand two
200 and sorry 102 82 958 and an
additional 12 300 with second doses and
28 000 with books second dose
appointment so that process is going on
uh
and moving forward really effectively i
think that there's often a discussion
about
differences
in uh between vaccinated and
unvaccinated but
what that represents is 93.1 percent of
people
who are
have received their first dose
immunization of adults who received
their first dose immunization
against covet 19. so when we talk about
divisions it's 16 people vaccinated for
every one person unvaccinated and i
think what we see in fact
and we've seen in our vaccination effort
from our
our teams of medical professionals of
our teams of volunteers of our teams of
communities and municipalities who have
supported it and of the many and of the
millions of people including the more
than four million people who
have and are using their bc vaccine card
extraordinary amount of consensus in our
joint effort and our joint commitment to
one another to help us get through this
and we see this every day
in every way
across the system we see it with family
members finding different ways to
support people in long-term care and the
announcements made by dr henry are
gratifying for many people in this group
we see it in how we help one another we
see it in people
sometimes dropping off meals when people
are in isolation to make their lives
better we see it
everywhere and i think well there is a
lot of always going to be discussion of
divergence and conflict
the level of consensus and collective
effort here in bc is something of which
we should all be very proud and i
certainly have in particular
i want to provide an update today on
where we are in terms of acute care just
not in terms of people in the hospital
uh
with co with a positive test for covet
19 dr henry has been talking about that
but um overall in the system as you know
there are 9 229 base beds in our system
today
8776 of those are full we have 2 353
surge beds across the acute care system
today 582 of those
are full so that's a
a total of people in
in
our acute care system that is um
that is 9 358 so that is above the base
level well below obviously the basin
surge bed level but what it tells you is
that our hospitals are very busy
providing exceptional care to a lot of
people in terms of critical care we have
510
base critical care beds and 218 surge
beds of the 510 beds
448 of those are full today of the 218
surge beds uh 30 of those are full today
so that's a total
of 478 people in critical care
i want to give a brief update on the
impact of sickness on health care
workers in the healthcare system health
authorities obviously continue to
closely monitor sickness levels across
health services especially in hospitals
long-term care and home support
i can report from january 24th to 30th
17 756 health care workers called in
sick
that includes 4033 in fraser health 3400
in interior health
1656 in northern health
1773 in the provincial health services
authority that includes the bc emergency
health services two 2714 in vancouver
coastal health
3406 in island health and 718 in
providence healthcare this is the number
of health care workers affected and does
not reflect the number of days or shifts
they may have called in sick the illness
could be judicious 19 or something else
the number of healthcare workers as you
can tell is relatively unchea
unchanged from last week or the week
before so the situation remains very
challenging very difficult but
it is not getting demonstrably better in
terms of overall sickness or worse over
the last couple of weeks it is staying
remarkably in fact similar in terms of
the statistics i want to thank everybody
working in healthcare it goes without
saying i think but we should say it
again and again if we can we've been
working exceptionally hard under
enormous pressure to get british
columbians through this pandemic and to
provide exceptional services
in in communities across bc with respect
to rapid tests bc has received now
received
as of january 31st 2020 10 million 187
385 rapid tests and deployed 5 million
twenty 927 thousand two hundred and
eighty four of these tests to key
strategic area
this leaves the current inventory of
four million two hundred and sixty
thousand one hundred one tests
two million six hundred and fifty eight
thousand of which we received in the
last three days so
since
on the weekend and since
as
you know as we've discussed before 556
896 of these tests are not packaged
suitably for take away our personal use
leaving three million seven hundred and
three thousand two hundred five tests
that are suitable for self-administered
use
this week subject to timely delivery
from the federal government we will be
working to deliver over one million two
hundred ninety one thousand test kits as
follows
351 000 for repackaging and distribution
to covet test sites across bc to
replenish their supply
a hundred thousand to replenish supply
in uh
at acute care centers for symptomatic
health care workers and health authority
programs for example emergency
departments 260 000 to support testing
of visitors and symptomatic staff and
long-term care and symptomatic staff in
assisted living
130 000 to support rural remote and
indigenous communities three hundred
thousand more tests to support k-12
education
as more tests arrive we will continue to
push to the areas in greatest need and
expand across post-secondary child care
in other areas as identified in the plan
that was presented on december twenty
first twenty twenty one
currently bc and this is a change
expects to receive sixteen million five
hundred ninety seven thousand five
hundred fifteen tests between today
february first and the middle of
february this is an increase from the
fifteen million seven hundred nineteen
thousand nine hundred twenty that we
were expecting as of january twentieth
and an increase from the number that we
provided last week this is good news
clearly the supply test is substantial
but it's also in flux as orders and
deliveries get firmed up by the federal
government
and finally i want to provide our weekly
surgical renewal update health
authorities um
uh
reported uh in the week of january 2nd
to january 8th which included a
statutory holiday
4976 surgeries were completed in that
week
from january 23rd to january 29th health
authorities postponed 870 non-urgent
scheduled surgeries that's 104 in fraser
health 15 in vancouver coastal health
572 in interior health
171 in island health 8 in the provincial
health services authority
no surgeries were postponed in the
northern health authority
and just to put that in context that's a
significant number and it's impacting a
lot of people in a lot of families
although it's significantly less when
the suspension of non-urgent um
scheduled surgeries in the april and may
uh 2020 period of in the first
phase the first
wave of the pandemic
cumulatively from september 5th to 20
2021 to january 29 2022
regional services surges of covet 19 and
factors including severe weather
patterns have caused
6762 surgical postponements
as reported there are over a thousand
people
and there will be today
in hospital with covet there's still a
very significant number although less
relatively speaking compared to the
total number than before in our
intensive care units
and we're still losing loved ones to
covet on a daily basis
while there's more important progress on
other fronts that reflect our hard work
to stop the spread we know this and this
is something we do together in british
columbia and we've done together very
effectively we know our work is not no
done we know this too that our actions
to slow covet's current surge have a
direct impact on our health care
system's capacity to perform in the many
ways we count on it to perform to do the
many things we rely on it to do and to
deliver the remarkable outcomes we've
come to expect from it patients will get
their calls to rebook their surgeries
healthcare workers and teams will get
the respite they need from kovitz
current push and all of us will share in
the relief those achievements bring when
we continue to do the work that many
that so many are counting on us to
continue
to do
keep wearing our mask
keep using our physical distance keep
using our covet sense keep adhering to
health orders keep embracing health
guidelines keep getting vaccinated in
these exceptional numbers
and keep protecting our children with
their vaccinations and getting our third
shots and boosters when it's our turn
that's our work
and when we do it we make all the
difference in the moments that matter
and with that we're happy to take your
questions
as a reminder to reporters on the phone
please press star one to enter the queue
you will be limited to one question and
one follow-up and i'm just going to give
a quick update on one other issue that i
have missed my notes on
we talked last week and the national
advisory committee on immunization came
out with recommendations around booster
doses for 12 to 17 year olds
and they did confirm a six-month
interval was the interval to be used
they also uh
confirmed and this is something that
we'll be
making sure people have access to later
this week
that people who similar to adults who
have
in the 12 to 17 year age group who have
clinically
extremely vulnerable have immune
compromising conditions and a few other
conditions
are
should get a third dose as part of your
primary series and then a fourth booster
dose six months after that so that will
affect some people who are immune
compromised in that age group
and you'll be receiving your invitations
for that
for other people in the 12 to 17 year
age group
nasi has recommended uh the that a
booster dose be provided to people who
are at high risk and we uh for a number
of conditions and we have those outlined
at six months of age that's people with
diabetes people with
a number of other conditions that
increase the risk of having more severe
illness
and for others it is in nasties opinion
more of an optional risk benefit
analysis that you do yourself so how we
will be doing it here in bc after
discussion with our bc immunization
committee and our
immunization team we will be sending
invites to all 12 to 17 year olds
with information on the benefits and
risks of boosters at your six-month
interval and you will be have the
ability to make that decision and book
yourself and we do of course continue to
strongly recommend that anybody who has
an underlying condition that puts them
at risk does get their booster dose we
have seen and we see it in the
hospitalization data that it's important
for protection not only against
infection even from overcrowd but also
uh
really important for longer term
protection against severe illness
so i'll leave that at that and then we
can start for questions that our first
question today will be from binder
sergeant ctv please go ahead
um
dr henry i know you said that the
information would be up on the website
but can you explain a little bit about
how the criteria for declaring an
outbreak in care homes is changing what
it's going to be and
we're hearing that this change may have
been made in late december or early
january can you tell us sort of when it
goes into effect or when it went into
effect and exactly what the new um
criteria are safe
so as you know we we had guidance that
was posted up on our uh on the bccdc
website and these are public health
guidance that
mhos use on a case-by-case basis to make
a determination and they're based on the
the information and i've talked about
this a few times that we have from our
our regular respiratory uh infection
outbreak guidelines and long-term care
homes and so they were quite
prescriptive about the things that must
be done if there was evidence of
transmission within a facility so that
included a single positive case in a
resident or
more than one case in a staff person
where there was transmission within the
facility or potential exposures so that
was an important
very sensitive definition that served us
well with the serious
illness that we were seeing with
multiple
different strains of the virus and
particularly before we had vaccinations
and before we had booster doses so we
are now seeing it is qualitatively very
different in long-term care homes with
omicron and because there is so much
spreading in the community we see rates
background rates in long-term care homes
as well so it is much more around a
changing situation whether there's
severe illness so a more symptomatic
illness we're no longer doing
asymptomatic testing screening of
everybody
looking at uh
who's getting the vaccination levels
whether it's more serious whether other
uh respiratory viruses are calling it so
it has always been at the judgment of
the mho doing the investigation of each
of the
of the outbreaks
but declaring an outbreak is a little
more nuanced now
based on what we're seeing in a highly
vaccinated population
both workers visitors and and residents
in particular
and the measures that we're putting in
place in an outbreak are not as extreme
as the ones that we had in place and i
talked about you know overall measures
but
especially outbreak measures so that's
still ensuring that a vaccinated
protected visitor can come in for every
resident even during an outbreak so that
they get that extra support that they
need for example and there's a few other
things that are
part of that as well and yes this has
been an evolution as we've very similar
to the hospital data as we've seen delta
fade away
and omicron uh causing very mild illness
in many cases
in both staff and residents
binder did you have a follow-up
yeah i just wanted to ask about the
rapid pass it seems like pretty big
numbers are coming in now for the
province um we know people now are
turning to facebook groups for instance
to try and find out which pharmacies may
have them um and wondering why they
don't have access to some of those rapid
tests that are now coming in this month
um some people need to know or need to
show a positive test for work purposes
for taking sick days but um is there a
plan to distribute those uh rapid tests
that are coming in in a more
um
you know where people can just pick them
up at testing sites because you know
people want to know whether they have
coveted or not
yeah i'll let the minister take that one
so we laid out a very detailed plan uh
been there on december 21st as to where
our priorities were for the use of rapid
tests british columbia as you can see by
the large numbers coming in to the
province are getting its full share of
rapid tests 13.5 percent of the national
supply and we're using them in these
priority areas so i think i said
noted that
if you're talking about 10 million rapid
tests that's less than two per person
and we're using them in priority in in
areas such as long-term care acute care
to support uh
our testing sites where they where
they're there in schools in
post-secondary and some work sites in
areas where there's congregate living
and others to ensure that people are
safe and that is you see in detail today
the way those tests are distributed
across the system so that's what we're
doing as we get more we may be able to
extend that more widely but those are
going to continue to be the priorities
probably continue to be our health care
system continue to be supporting k-12
education and post-secondary education
continue to be to support child care
continue to be
to support certain workplaces where the
risk is highest and they're of course a
part of today's announcement around
visitors in long-term care so that is
that utilization as you can tell by the
numbers being distributed to those areas
this week
i think it's about 1.3 million that's a
lot of use of rapid tests across those
systems of the supply we get
the rapid tests we're going to get we're
going to use and the only exceptions to
that
are the ones that we're drawing down
more slowly which are ones that require
specialized equipment or a healthcare
worker and so we're going to continue to
do that over time and obviously as we
get more we'll be able to somewhat widen
that but those are going to continue to
be the priority areas we've laid it out
in detail what we're doing and it's not
dissimilar to what lots of other
jurisdictions are doing as well but this
is our priority which is to protect the
most vulnerable protect the healthcare
system and to ensure that critical
things such as to support critical
services for parents and children such
as k-12
education child care and post-secondary
education
our next question is from rob shaw check
please go ahead
could i just
get you to walk us through the essential
and designated visitor situation again i
guess i find it a little bit confusing
if
seniors have essential visitors now but
only one third of them actually have
that declared and the concern is that
it's the care home administrators who
can decide if a senior's
essential visitor is actually an
essential visitor and you've said today
during an outbreak under the changes
essential visitors can still go in and
visit
can a designated
visitor still go in and visit
and a designated visitor doesn't have to
be approved by the care home
administrator could you just walk
through the differences there and what
it means for seniors that's absolutely
what it means so we have a process in
place already and as we've mentioned
about a third of seniors and residents
of long-term care have somebody who
needs to be there as part of their care
team helps
provide that extra care and those people
have been identified already what we are
moving towards and what we have moved
towards as i've mentioned since
the end of december is making sure that
in addition
every single resident at their choice
can designate
somebody to be their visitor and you can
have a backup in case somebody's ill or
can't come in so
yes if you have you can have
if you have two children one of them can
be yours essential visitor if they're
already designated and you can have
another person come in to be your
visitor and that's what we want across
the board that's what's
aligned with what the the representative
for seniors or the seniors advocate has
suggested whether we think it's really
important and they yes can come
regardless regardless of the
transmission rates in the community
regardless of whether it's an outbreak
in a facility they will need to be
because we know that it's still pretty
risky they'll need to be vaccinated
themselves and that's why we're
prioritizing long-term care for making
sure we can test people with rapid tests
as well so
those are at the residents choice
and every resident is entitled to have
their designated visitor who can come at
any time and that's in addition to those
people who have already been identified
as essential visitors
does that make it
clear rob did you have a follow-up
great thank you yeah um mr dix can i ask
you to comment on the victoria woman
who yesterday got a call from nurses at
royal jubilee hospital to come and ask
her to come feed her 87 year old mother
there for three meals because there
wasn't enough staff apparently the
family had to do that again today as
well is that acceptable
do we know if other families are being
asked to do this
and what happens if a patient doesn't
have family who can come in and feed
them
well to the latter question no one's
ever denied obviously
care or left without being fed and
and so that that simply doesn't happen
and would not happen
in those circumstances what does happen
and i can't comment on the case i just
just so that everyone understands that
regardless of the public comment around
the case we can't come up with the
information we have which are part of
the privacy afforded to people in our
health care system so we don't comment
on the individual cases what happens and
what happens frequently this is before
the pandemic is and now
is that visitors frequently help with
care either because they want to or
because it's
their
the patient who's a relative may ask
them to or because uh the care staff
think that's a good idea and that
frequently happened before and after so
it's not an issue of um the
the individuals being called in to do
that but that it can be a helpful
situation uh for many involved there's
no question
that there's uh staffing challenges you
saw in the numbers we provided in
vancouver island health right now but
there's also no question that everyone
is going to be
fed in that process but sometimes people
get asked to come in and help especially
when they're providing care around and
again this is not about this case i'm
not commenting about the case but and
and that i think uh happened before the
pandemic it happens now and will
continue to happen so the issue isn't uh
we're
that people aren't going to be fed of
course they're going to be fed the
question is whether um staff ask
for a variety of reasons for family
members to come in and assist and and
often that's a very good thing
sometimes for the family members
sometimes certainly for the patient that
that happened but in no circumstances
would someone not be fed and
i think that would probably be obvious
to everybody but
this is an important question and very
appreciative of
the family's concern and if there's
specific complaint there's an
independent process to review those
complaints i encourage people to take it
to those processes as they have
complaints about the healthcare system
because that's important it's also
important to know our care staff
and it's been one of the challenges
throughout the covet 19 pandemic in
long-term care as we've just discussed
in acute care is
often families and visitors play a very
important role
in uh in supporting the care and the
recovery of people in both acute care
and long-term care and in other
health circumstances so
the short answer is everybody gets fed
but this is not unusual that visitors
whether they be essential or otherwise
be asked to contribute to that and i i
gather
without commenting on it but from
hearing what's been reported in the news
that's what happened in this case but
those are the circumstances anyway and
uh and obviously we want to make sure
that everybody is well treated so that
their recovery and the support for
whatever brings them to hospital is is
well supported in our system
our next question is for richard dussman
global news
dr henry
pfizer is now working through the
process of getting its vaccine approved
for those under the age of five so i
think from six months to five years old
at what point do you expect to see that
vaccine available uh here in british
columbia and what would your initial
thoughts be around people of that age uh
getting the kova 19 vaccines yeah so yes
i've been watching uh that with interest
um this was uh the fda in the u.s uh
suggesting that pfizer uh start the
process of applying for
emergency use authorization which is
slightly different from the process that
we have here with health canada
the and we've talked about this before
that the initial dosing tests on on
children and that age group
indicated a one-tenth dose
so slightly different from the pediatric
formulation we have right now but the
the immunogenicity studies they did so
that's seeing if they give that dose
to
that age group of children
if they have a similar
antibody response to what we see in
adults that we know is protective so
it's what we call a correlative immunity
and what they found was they weren't
getting as strong an immune response and
partly this is because our immune system
develops over time when we're when we're
very young and sort of the the ultimate
time frame for a strong immune system is
in that sort of um six to
15 to 20 year age group which is why
you know we've seen such great uh
benefits from vaccine and in
the kids in that age group and teenagers
so the short answer is they are
continuing and the fda and others in the
us
asked pfizer to add a third dose to the
protocol for that age group but what
they're doing given the rates of
transmission they're seeing and the
hospitalization rates in younger
children in the u.s the fda has said go
ahead and put in the application with
the data that you have for the first two
doses and then by the time we have the
opportunity as we have seen it takes
months
in many cases to review that data to
understand the data and to look at it in
detail they should have results of of
the third dose part of the study so it
is
looking at ways of starting immunization
programs for younger children in a high
risk environment where there's a lot of
transmission still in many parts of the
country
in
as the as the continued testing of how
many doses is actually needed is ongoing
so that's kind of complex
as far as i know health canada has not
yet
taken that approach and we're still
waiting for the information from
pfizer and the data on the first two
doses and the third dose
having said that you know
it is important and we have seen young
children being affected by covid
we've had admissions to hospital in the
zero to four age group we've had two
young toddlers one toddler one infant
who who've died from covet over the
course of our pandemic
and we know that it can cause severe
illness in young ones so it is important
that we have a vaccine that can protect
especially those highest risk children
in that age group
and we'll be looking to health canada to
review the safety and effectiveness data
as it becomes available here i don't
think it will happen in the short term
but i do expect that as soon as pfizer
gets the more detailed data they will
submit it here and to health canada as
well
richard did you have a follow-up
dr henry i'm receiving a lot of notes
from people who are
trying to plan trips outside of the
country for uh spring break and one of
the challenges they are facing is around
a potential uh covert diagnosis because
of
the limited testing capacity here many
of them were not able to get tested as
you are aware i'm sure if you have a pcr
test confirmed uh you uh don't you there
are certain rules around travel in terms
of getting retested
all of this considered would bc
consider
providing documentation for those who
tested positive on rapid tests to allow
for that travel and what conversations
have you had with the federal
with your federal counterparts around
changing some of these confusing uh
travel protocols that could be
prohibited for people who in bc were
never able to get a pcr test
so this is not unique to people in bc
and yes there are some
i will say that the the publicly funded
testing system is not for for private
personal travel like that so no it's not
available in our
you know pcr tests in our publicly
funded system needs to be
focused on the people for whom they're
it'll make a difference in terms of
either their care or being going back to
work
there are some provisions in places i
know in uh in private clinics to be able
to get a confirmation uh associated with
a rapid test positive um at a person's
own expense like other travel clinic
services that are provided
uh and
you know
it's very hard to
as you know there's a trajectory of
antibodies that are picked up by these
tests so if we're talking out in march
somebody who had an infection now um is
unlikely to test positive on a pcr test
that far out
but those are things that are very
challenging things and yes the federal
government is reviewing particularly as
in the provinces and territories we've
changed our isolation requirements for
people who are contacts and for people
who are who test positive and they're
not aligned anymore with some of the
border measures so we have had ongoing
discussions about the border measures
and what tests are required when and why
and i know they are reviewing those
um in the next few weeks
our next question today is from lisa
cordasco vancouver son please go ahead
thank you um i want to talk about the
changes to how you are going to adjust
outbreak management uh your management
approach um
in changing
uh when a medical health officer may
declare an outbreak
some would say that you know outbreak
should still be declared because then
visitors and residents of care homes
know
and can judge whether they will continue
to go to activities or whether visitors
will be continuing to visit
declaring an outbreak just simply tells
the public that there is colleagues
circulating in a care home
medical health officers from that point
on could use their discretion to say yes
visits will continue or
um activities will continue um is that
the approach that you're using and if
not is leaving enough to declare an
outbreak in a care home
how is members how are members of the
public or you know visitors or even
residents in care homes
to actually know
that there is a coveted circulating in
their facility
there's lots of things that are packed
into that and it is a little bit
the the mho is not in every facility
every day and of the 200 and some that
are
in our province and it is that community
that understands what's going on and yes
we liaise with each individual facility
the facilities themselves and our teams
and the regional health authorities that
include the mhos it includes infection
control they are in constant contact
with the different facilities about what
they're seeing so the people what we're
seeing now is that yes there may be a
resident who tests positive for for
covin may have mild symptoms but test
positive and they are individually
isolated in their room we have overall
provisions in place so that you only go
visit your one person you wear a mask
you're tested staff are tested regularly
if they have any symptoms they wear ppe
all the time so there is measures in
place that help reduce the risk of
transmission and there are people who
are asymptomatic who have this in our
community now and that includes in
long-term care homes so all of these
other things help reduce that risk and
if somebody tests positive they know
their roommates know and are isolated if
they have roommates
their families are notified
and they they aren't
able to participate in group activities
so it is a matter of finding that
balance of knowing uh if there's a few
cases but there's not a lot of
transmission happening you can isolate
those individuals
very effectively now because so many
people are vaccinated and because we
have these other measures in place
so that's on a home by home basis how
we're managing right now and then if
there's more transmission that's not
that we're not sure who's passing it to
who it's more severe illness and we've
had that with rsv and we've had it with
delta still causing a couple of
infections
then we need to take more additional
measures and
give more detailed notification to the
broader community
but it is trying to find that
disruption of people's life and ability
to be with their loved ones
versus risk
right now
lisa did you have a follow-up
yes i can appreciate that care homes
would be taking measures to reduce risk
but my question is about the declaration
of outbreaks that triggers an actual
public warning
that
that um covet is circulating in a care
home people can make their own decisions
after that but
and including medical health officers to
decide you know what protocols are going
to take place in any care home
my question is you know
you're abandoning that requirement that
people be informed if you don't declare
an outbreak so
and then not declaring enough i think
giving them all kinds of options aren't
we going to be all over the place but
where an outbreak is and isn't and
what's going on isn't going on why not
just declare outbreaks and then decide
protocols for handling it lead that to
the discretion of medical health offices
this is you know this is what we do
in
in long-term care homes have done for
many many years and it is about finding
that balance in that judgment and if
there's not influenza influenza kovid's
circulating we may have cases we may
have individual people we may have rooms
where there are individuals who have
covet there may be a number of staff
who have covet who are off and no longer
in the facility those don't
constitute circulation within the
facility that puts people at risk right
now so it is finding that balance in
that judgment and we don't need to tell
uh in your 300 bed facility that one
person has covered
you know it's finding that balance right
now given what we're seeing
circulating and it is very much
a part of a relationship that we have
and a really good relationship now where
people are taking additional measures on
a daily basis
to make sure that they're protecting
themselves and their loved ones
and
their their fellow workers in
long-term care homes
our next question is for lisa eustace
city news please go ahead
hi there i'm wondering with all the
information that you've laid out today
dr henry and and talking about you sound
a little bit optimistic that by february
16th at least some things are going to
be lifting but laying out you know how
it's affecting hospitalizations and icu
are we sort of looking at going the way
of denmark and england that we are
really going to see a large lifting of
regulations
in the weeks or months to come
i think i made it quite clear that we're
still on the
ratcheting up the dial versus on and off
switches so there's some things that we
know are working and give people the
ability to do
higher risk activities more safely
things like the bc vaccine card these
things like some of the higher risk
settings having capacity limits so
wearing masks in indoor settings
especially some of the higher risk
indoor settings so
there are some things that we will need
to continue to do for another period of
time i do absolutely think that we'll be
able to lift them at some point and
we'll have no restrictions but
i do think at some point we're going to
get to a place where we can
think about having those important life
events again in a limited way and
gradually increasing that to a place
where we can have
larger groups of people together for
for wedding ceremonies and celebrations
of life and birthday parties and all
those important things that we've been
missing this last
few months
lisa did you have a follow-up
i do and this one's probably more for
minister dicks but not sure regarding
the rapid tests in your response i think
richard asked the question so you're
saying that there's 4.2 million
that are around right now 500 000 can't
be used
and so that's you know nearly 3 million
sitting there so i just i guess people
are left scratching their heads why
there isn't a process by which
more people can have access to them when
there's
uh that many
that seem to be sitting there when
they're just you know people really
haven't seen them much at school but
they're just starting to trickle in or
universities so is it just that we
haven't seen them in
broad numbers at those places where
people want to access them and and
people are really scratching their heads
about why they can't be more broadly
accessible when there's this many
millions sitting there
but you think it just i'll add to that
just you know there's 600 000 children
in in
k to 12. there's another well you know
how many staff are in in k-12 plus
post-secondary institutions and so you
know 3 million sounds like a lot but
they're also packaged in
packages that they're not
three million individual packages of
tests and
that's you know what
three tests for every school child so
it's not a lot uh when you look at it
from that perspective so
and yes they are getting into those
settings now
and many of them just came in in the
last couple of days as you know but i'll
let the minister talk to details
so um you talk about three million tests
we've had tests in the millions come in
in the last three days and what happens
is we come in we adjust we process them
and then they go out and i laid out in
detail where 1.2 million are going this
week
so what you're seeing i think
is us taking the test when they arrive
there's they're not always consistent on
their arrival and then distributing to
them to the areas of priority and those
areas of priority again
are acute care testing centers
long-term care assisted living schools k
to 12 schools post-secondary child care
workplaces congregate settings and
others that are priorities and have been
designed as priorities by public health
and by those who are driving the
initiative so there's there's none
sitting around we get millions come in
takes us some day to process them and
then they're going out and that's what
you're going to see you're going to see
a significant increase in that number in
the next couple of weeks so the next
time i report that will be many millions
more arrived and many millions more
distributed and so
nothing's waiting around
and we're giving priority to those areas
where we can have the biggest impact on
the pandemic and those are the areas
i've described and that's what we're
doing we're getting the tests coming in
the millions in a given three-day period
and then they're also going out in the
millions and that will continue to
happen so if you take it at a point of
time when four million tests say arrive
one day and you say well there are four
million tests well those will be going
out to those priority areas and you'll
be seeing them around the province and
and obviously we've been doing
dramatically more rapid testing in the
last few weeks as a result of the tests
we have
we have time for one more question our
final question today is from bell pury
cbc please go ahead
dr henry um by the end of this month
children five and up will have had time
to get both doses of vaccine so and many
of those in that age group have already
been exposed to it or have been mildly
sick and recovered from omicron so given
all of that when do you think school
might return to normal you know masking
would be optional no social distancing
field trips would be allowed and we need
a answer in french as well
please yeah you know um one doesn't
uh
i'm continually reminded of the uh
travails of speculating um you know i
kind of thought we were in a really good
place in in december until omicron hit
us and we still are seeing this virus
spreading rapidly around the globe we
still see new things coming up every day
whether it's you know the
um
the the ba 0.2 in in denmark in the uk
and and south africa now too and we've
had some of that here so
there's a whole lot of things that we
don't yet know
um and
some of the more
uh challenging things to implement in
schools are the ones that we hope to get
rid of first
but it will depend on
decreasing circulation rates in our
community and our balancing and our
health care system so i do think you
know by the time we get to spring
we're going to be in a very different
place i hope at least for a period of
time and this is my speculating a little
bit
with recognizing my optimism bias
but i do think with the level of
immunity that we have with the level of
protection we have through vaccination
with the amount of milder illness in
those vaccinated people that gives a
boost to your immunity for a period of
time as well that we're likely to have a
gentler spring and hopefully summer and
we'll need to prepare ourselves
and all areas for
more unknowns come the fall because it
is
pretty sure that this virus is going to
come back in some form
in the fall and hopefully it will be in
a form that is still
we still have good protection from the
booster doses of vaccine that we've had
and that we can manage our health care
system
uh
[Music]
the circumstances
[Music]
did you have a follow-up
dr henry i i think you said 60 of covert
cases in hospitals or among patients
admitted for other reasons so how much
is that related to the policy of not
keeping covert patients separate putting
them in rooms with vaccinated people how
much is that a contributing factor
english and french please
i'm not sure i understand your question
are you asking whether there's been
uh transmission in hospital because we
put people with a cova-positive test
in a room with somebody who's
low risk and covet negative
right like when we're hearing any
transmission
so
you know what we are seeing is people
are being admitted
to hospital for surgery
actually where we're seeing it most
commonly is surgery
people being screened for surgery people
being screened at labor and delivery
people being screened for mental health
and substance use admissions and some of
them are testing positive they are
asymptomatic
and precautions are put in place to make
sure that
while the time the the period of time
that they have
a positive test that they aren't um able
to transmit it to others um but i'm not
aware of any
uh
transmission from
having people in a
in a room together i guess
unless you unless i'm missing the
question sorry
bill did you want to clarify your
question
well no i mean that i think
we've been hearing that uh coveted
positive patients and vaccinated
people are in
rooms together so we're just wondering
if you've had cases of transmission in
those situations do any of these people
who go to hospital for a non-covered
reason and end up being positive for
covid then they get it there
yeah so we have had a number of acute
care outbreaks as you see in our
outbreak report and that's where
somebody was unknown to be uh
to have covet and it's been transmitted
in in a acute care setting
but there's been no transmission
from a known covet positive person
being in a placed in a room or ward with
other
vaccinated low-risk people according to
the infection control policy that we
talked about a couple of weeks ago
[Music]
what we see and this is a difference in
the delta period when you have overall
test positivity of three or four percent
in the society based on our pcr testing
as a sample of the overall
society of people and that goes up to
what it's been 24 then you're going to
see an increased number of people who
aren't coming in for code that are
coming from other reasons but are also
positive for covet and that's what we're
seeing and that's what the numbers
reflect
um the change the the
approach to how we treat people in the
hospital continues to be the same where
possible when people
are positive for kovadesna uh
for uh covet 19 it it is
they are
cohorted away from the general
population it's just not always possible
when you've got as we did today 9 300
people in the hospital and 1 000 and
30 or so of them are with kovades uh
covet 19 and that's what in different in
different hospitals those numbers of
course individual hospitals are
different so cohorting is not always
possible but it's certainly
the direction and fraser health was
making some adjustments to that but what
you're seeing is not evidence of what
you're talking about about what you're
seeing is the change in the pandemic
from delta to omicron and with that
merciful thank you until we until the
next time thank you